plants of course are going to be a major
component in the future of this planet
of humanity on the planet in two very
large areas one of course is in food
production as the human population
increases food becomes more and more
important but also in biofuels which
have great potential for reducing carbon
atmospheric carbon and reducing reliance
on fossil fuels in both cases the
ability to clone plants is very
important
most of the major energy crops that are
currently used for example sugarcane
even oil palm and and and some some
grasses that are like Miscanthus and
switchgrass that are being proposed as
non-food biofuel crops are all
propagated as clients and so the
epigenetic changes that they undergo
need to be understood one of the big
problems with biofuels that has economic
problems of biofuels that has come to
light in the last few years is that of
course if we use food crops for biofuels
this pushes up the price of food and so
there's been a great interest in the
last few years to find alternatives to
food crops that don't grow on arable
land and instead can be used
specifically for biofuels we've become
very interested in aquatic plants as a
possibility here and one of the most
impressive aquatic clouds from a biofuel
point of view is common duck weed the
reason for this is that duck weed
doubles in biomass every 48 hours
sometimes even less and as a result it
has the highest per hectare increase in
biomass of any plant even though it's a
very small plant
they're quite they're amazing organisms
does anyone who who has a pond will know
especially if that pond is for example
on a golf course or something like that
where there's a lot of fertilizer put
into the ground the fertilizer will run
off into the into the pond and duck weed
is actually a very efficient user of
wastewater if you like it can convert
high nitrogen and high phosphorous water
into much cleaner water
and at the same time massively increase
in biomass so we're interested in using
or optimizing duckweed for uses as a
biomass biofuel based on its mobility to
grow on wastewater and water in places
which you've never imagined crops would
grow there are various ways to do this
we're taking we're taking a lesson from
the another very popular biofuel which
is algae green algae so a green algae
have the ability again to grow in water
and at very high rates but they also
have the ability to make oil directly
and this has been very exciting in the
in the biofuels community however it's
still energetically is not efficient to
make oil from algae you put more energy
in mostly from artificial light and and
and keeping things sterile and and so on
then you get out in the form of oil now
duckweed is much more robust organism
it's it's a real plant and so it can
grow outdoors it doesn't have big
pathogen problems and it could go very
very fast so if we can persuade duckweed
to make oil instead of starch we would
be a long way on the path to making a
really efficient but i feel
you